I'm saying like this is like this is why
the men like see these laws as unfair
and this is this is why they don't see
this as Fair because I hear 2500 a month
and I I personally think and this is I
grew up in a one percent family okay
like this is I I had the life like sort
of we were like kind of like rich people
that like dressed for you know what I
mean but but it's like like I hear 2500
a month I'm like that's plenty for a kid
and I'm not I'm not trying to no that's
fine I don't I don't think it's gonna
like like damage a kid if they once in a
Lamborghini once in a Honda Civic but
I'm telling you that's up to judge
that's up to the judge and that's up to
law and again so if you're if you are in
it like I said it's like greater than
equal to so if you're using a 1.6
million dollar house a 500 000 house 400
000 house makes sense like I'm not
saying you have to be 1.6 a million like
that's not what it is so like I said
people are allowed to feel that way I
would love if people were just out of
the business in general the court system